GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: I
think I can start.
Sounds like everyone
can hear me.
Welcome to the first
session of the morning.
I'm glad you all chose to
learn more about App Engine.
In particular, Appstats,
which is a tool for
App Engine developers.
Either Python or Java to learn
more about the performance
of their application.
So quick overview of the talk.
Note the wave URL and the
Twitter tag at the bottom.
Please use those for
any interaction.
I'm going to give a little bit
of an introduction, a demo
of the tool of course.
Some background, what you would
do to write your own tool like
this because there's actually
not really any magic involved.
How to configure
it, how to use it.
Hopefully I'll have plenty of
time to talk about the number
of specific performance issues
that we found in various
applications that I wrote or
colleagues wrote or early users
wrote where Appstats turned out
to be very helpful for
performance analysis.
So the high order bits of
Appstats is it's a tool library
that you link in with your
App Engine application.
It is specific for App Engine
and it analyzes your remote
procedure call performance.
It's available for
Python since February.
Java since March.
The tools work the same, they
have the same user interface.
The actual implementation that
is linked into your application
is somewhat different.
This is a very quick graphical
overview of the main timeline
view that gives you most of the
insights in your application.
From here on you can also drill
down to specific things like
stack trace corresponding
to each call basically.
It shows you what the total
time was taken up by your
request, what RPC calls it made
and where those RPC calls were
relative to the timeline and
how long they took of course.
And then the red bars show you
how much you were charged
for each of those RPC calls.
Some basics as I
mentioned, Appstats is
a user-land library.
It's just linked with
your application.
There is no special system
calls, no support in the
App Engine server for
this tool specifically.
It has a little bit of
run-time overhead.
I'll get into that more later.
I think the run-time
overhead is pretty minimal.
The APIs it uses to do all its
instrumentation magic are
existing APIs that had
been added to the App
Engine APIs long ago.
Some of the instrumentation
APIs it uses are actually
standard Python APIs.
Others, for like measuring
things specific to RPCs
are App Engine specific.
There's no need to
download anything.
This is part of the standard
software development kit that
you already have when you start
developing with App Engine.
I mean, that's your
only download.
There's no extra download
just for this tool.
You do have to do a little
bit of configuration.
If you're using Java it's
that about 10 lines of XML.
If you're using Python it's
about four lines of Python
and two lines of YML.
And finally, the user interface
for this tool and that is
somewhat unusual perhaps, but
suitable for something that is
self-contained in all user-land
code, user interface is
actually part of the library.
What is the main thing you
can do with Appstats?
I would say probably the most
important thing you can do is
find which parts of your
application, which specific
request handlers are expensive
and which RPC calls, for
example, a particular database
query or a call to send e-mail
or fetch an external URL are
the hottest parts of
your application.
So if you're taking Don Knuth's
paradigm too heart, which says,
to avoid premature optimization
you write a correct application
first then you tackle
optimization and these tools
show you where to start doing
that optimization so you only
have to touch a small
amount of your code.
Now Appstats records everything
about every single remote
procedure call made
by your application.
In App Engine pretty much
everything is a remote
procedure call whether it's
sending email or fetching an
external URL or making a
call to the datastore
or even memcache.
All those things are
considered RPCs.
The tool shows you, as I
already showed briefly,
shows you a timeline of
individual requests.
It also shows some overview of
sort of global statistics.
How many requests of
each type did you get?
How many RPCs of each type
did you make and sort of a
combination of which requests
caused most of the RPCs
of each particular type.
The timeline in most cases
is the most important tool
to find out where the
time actually goes.
And the Python version at least
lets you drill down to the
content of stack frames so you
can view local variables, which
is often very helpful in
finding out why a particular
call is being made.
So now it's time to go
demo, do a little demo.
I'll start actually-- always
a little tricky to find the
right window-- OK, this
is an application.
It's called Rietveld.
It's also called Code Review.
It runs on Apps.
I wrote it about two
years ago actually as
a demo for App Engine.
It has a number of
interesting features.
It allows you to lets
see how fast it is.
Yes, it allows you to view
patches, comment on them.
I'm not going to go into
much detail there.
The important thing is that
we have an Appstats window
connected to this application.
Actually months ago I linked
Appstats into Rietveld and all
I have to do now is go to the
stats URL and see what the
most recent statistics were.
And this is a pretty
overwhelmingly
window I'm afraid.
Let's see if I can find a
smaller version of this.
This is an earlier snapshot
that I took this morning
after resetting the data
collection briefly.
So we have three sections
of the overview UI.
On the left we have everything
ordered by RPC calls.
So datastore next, datastore
get, datastore run query.
On the right we have everything
grouped by particular calls
into the applications.
So slash is a popular request.
Repos is another one.
And then various
diff-related requests.
At the bottom we see the entry
point to the next important
part of the application,
which this is just a
log of recent requests.
So actually this snapshot was
taken a few seconds after I
reset the data gathering
so the log only has
seven entries or so.
Let's go back to
the current one.
So we scroll down.
We see that there have
been a lot more calls
since this morning.
Here we have some of the
more recent requests.
I think this is probably
going to be a nice one.
So here we have timeline of
this particular request.
At the top we see the request
that causes this particular
sequence of events to happen.
On the left we see exactly
which calls it made.
It made a memcache set call.
It had a datastore get call.
It ran four different queries
and somehow the second query
always comes out by far
the most expensive.
So it will be interesting
to drill down on that.
So let's click on
that second query.
We can click right there and
now it opens the stack find.
This is actually still the same
window, I just scrolled down to
the corresponding sequence.
So here is another view
off all those RPCs.
Again, the memcache set,
datastore get, but here
you see more detail.
You see the contents of the
request buffer, the contents of
the response buffer and then
the various stack frames.
So while data stored with py is
some internal library, db init
is in another internal library.
This is actually library
that you use to interact
with a data store.
Typically a data store
that probably has a
lower level library.
Then here views the
application code.
Let's see what was
on the stack.
So we see some local variables.
Drafts, issue, batchset, id.
If we want to know sort of
where this lives in source code
we can open the source code in
the new window and there is our
small little primitive
source code browser.
So we can see that all those
variables, like issue comes
directly into the query.
So to go back to the top there
are a few other things that
you can see about this
request right away.
If you were to click on this
link it would actually send
another request like
that to the server.
So this is that
particular view.
There it is.
I don't know who looked at
this thing, it wasn't me.
So there are a couple tabs.
The RPC stats shows
you how many calls of
each type it made.
How much real time was spent in
each of those calls and how
much time you were charged
for each of those calls.
Then there's the CGI
environment which shows you
basically the header and
some other information.
If you're using Python you'll
be familiar with this.
From this you can
reconstruct the request.
Like the host header
had this value.
This was the refer header, the
user agent header and so on.
And finally, in some cases it's
kind of useful to know exactly
what the search path for Python
modules was and so you
can see that here.
Back to the timeline and
now to the presentation.
I should mention that the
Java tool has a very
similar user interface.
You'll see that the
CGI environment and
the [? system ?]
path part are not present
in the user interface.
I'm not giving a live demo of
the Java version, however you
can hear more about this tool
in the Java context in tomorrow
morning's talk by Don
Schwartz and Toby Reyelts.
And by the way I heard in the
keynote this morning that the
Java version of Appstats has
also been integrated in Speed
Tracer which is in general a
browser side performance
analysis tool that has a
similar graphical user
interface as Appstats.
Speed Tracer has an optional
integration with Java
Appstats in the background.
And there's another talk going
on, which unfortunately you've
already missed because it's
going on simultaneously with
this one about Speed Tracer.
But I'll also show that
off a little bit.
So little bit about the
background of Appstats.
It's important to understand
exactly what a remote
procedure call is.
In the App Engine environment,
in the context of App Engine
it's a very, clearly defined
thing where it's a round trip
between your application and
something in the back end.
Now that something in the back
end could be Google's mail
service infrastructure.
It could be the App
Engine data store.
It could be the memcache server
dedicated to your application.
It could be any number
of those things.
It could also be an external
website that you've accessing
through URLfetch interface.
All those things are RPCs and
all those things are recorded
by Appstats so it's not
limited to database calls.
I should mention that in the
case of database calls and I
think we actually saw
an example of that.
If I can find that
window quickly.
Yeah, here these data store
next calls, they're actually
in a sense continuation
calls for large queries.
If a query returns under 20
results and under a megabyte of
data all you see in your RPC
stats is a single
run query call.
If your query is larger than
either of those numbers, more
than 20 results of more than a
megabytes of data returned
because of limitations in how
many results you can fetch at
one time, in one was response,
it's actually broken up
into multiple calls.
The first one of which will be
called run query and all the
subsequent ones will
be called next.
In general, if you see a lot of
next calls you're probably
doing inefficient queries
because it's unlikely that
one single request in your
application is interested in
hundreds of query results.
You're probably doing some
kind of computation.
It's good to off-line
more easily.
Anyway, why did I decide to
write a tool whose only purpose
it is to instrument through
remote procedure calls?
Well, looking at the timing, if
you look at the typical web
application running on App
Engine you'll just notice that
almost all your time-- and
again, I'll just show one of
our Appstats windows-- almost
all your real time goes to
waiting for queries or other
remote procedure calls.
The only place in this graph
where there is significant time
that is not spent waiting for
an RPC is somewhere here.
And I imagine that this is
where it's actually doing some
template expansion, but that's
a very small fraction of the
total response time of this
application because this took
over 800 milliseconds to
compute and almost 700 hundred
milliseconds of that
was pure RPC time.
So in a sense I have to admit
that Rietveld even after two
years is not all that
optimized, which makes it a
great topic for this
presentation of course.
So some statistics just to give
you a feel of how fast App
Engine is and you can use
Appstats to measure these
numbers for your
own application.
Writing a single entry
to the data store is 50
or 100 milliseconds.
And actually the size of the
entry is barely important.
What is much more important in
determining how long it
actually takes and also how
much you're charged for it is
actually the number of
properties in the data that
require indexing because
the index updates are
part of the write.
Getting an object, of course,
if you know the key is much
faster, but it still takes
10 or 20 milliseconds.
The fastest queries I've
measured were about
20 milliseconds.
I've seen them vary between
20 and 100 milliseconds.
If you're doing complex queries
by comparing a number of
different properties using
multiple indexes, even a query
that only returns a few
results can take half
a second sometimes.
Memcache is probably the
fastest API we have.
The fastest RPC.
Even a memcache call, one
round trip, can be 5
or 10 milliseconds.
The fastest I've seen is
about 4 milliseconds.
And realize that memcache is
just copying a number of bytes
in a single hash table look up.
There's no IO that goes on.
So all the time, all that 5 or
10 milliseconds that you spend
waiting for memcache is
purely network traffic.
You're application
makes the call.
The data is sent to
the memcache server.
Once the memcache server has
received the last byte of your
request it does its work.
Copies the response in
the outfield buffer
and then sends back.
And all the time
you're waiting.
I haven't measured it, but I
imagine that the actual times
spent in the memcache server
doing real work is probably
something like 10 or 100
microseconds and everything
else is just waiting for the
data to get from here
or to there and back.
Even though this is all of
course within one Google data
center using the fastest
network and hardware
available in the universe.
So anyway, because App Engine
applications are very networked
every operation you do, whether
it's memcache or datastore or
something else goes out to a
server that does the
actual work for you.
The typical application is
slowed down by how many remote
procedure calls it makes more
than by any other factor.
Meaning if you're thinking
about sort of traditional
optimization of your
application you might think of
things like oh, I'm using an n
square algorithm where I really
should be using a
log n algorithm.
That is not the important thing
in optimizing your web apps.
Well yes, it could be,
but it's unlikely.
It's much more likely that
you're making 10 RPC calls to
get the same object over and
over because you have some bug
in your application or you're
making 10 RPC calls to fetch 10
different objects that you
could just as well fetch in
a single batching RPC call.
So this is why ROC
instrumentation is so important
and why I recommended that
you all try this out.
So what does Appstats
use under the hood?
How is it implemented?
I have way more information
about this, but I decided
that there wasn't
enough time in my talk.
I don't want to go 30 minutes
over like the keynote.
So the one thing I want to
mention, there's a general
feature in App Engine, general
API, called call hooks where
any part of user code can
register a user function to be
called right at the
start of an RPC.
The function is called with a
number of arguments that tell
it exactly which kind of RPC
is being made and with
which request buffer.
And there's another function
you can register that gets
called when the RPC returns.
And that function also has the
response buffer of course and
it has information about
whether the request actually
succeeded or it failed.
This is most of the magic to
writing Appstats because all
we do is in the precall
hook as we call it.
We record the content of the
request buffer and we crawl
down the stack to record all
the stack frames and
local variables.
And then in the post call hook
we match that up with the
response and the error status
and then we write
that to memory.
This is just written to main
memory and in a typical
situation over the duration
of single request maybe
you collect a few
megabytes of data.
In modern processors that's
absolutely not a problem.
At the end of the request we
gather all that data that we've
collected, serialize it and
write it to memcachel and so of
course, we practice
what we preach.
We write two different pieces
of information to memcache.
We write a short summary
record that is used
by the summary page.
Let me see, what is
the summary page?
This is the summary page.
So it has information
about a whole bunch of
different requests.
So the way it gets this is by
crawling memcache looking for
every single summary record.
So the summary records have to
be small because memcache
doesn't have to give you a way
of say, only return the first
100 bytes of each record.
On the other hand, the long
details record of course is
used to reconstruct what you
see in this page, which
has much more information.
Look at all those stack traces.
There's a lot of data there.
Anyway, this data is
written to memcache.
That's the end of the
information gathering stage.
Then later at your leisure-- as
long as it hasn't expired out
of memcache of course-- you
point your browser at the UI,
which I mentioned before and
the UI just gets the
information from memcache
and displays it.
It's the little Django
template based application.
It's actually very simple.
Now everyone's question and I
know this was the first
question that showed up on the
wave a few days ago actually,
what is that overhead
of Appstats?
Well, I was interested in this
myself so I made sure that
I could figure it out.
First of all, the callback
functions that are used to
record the information actually
sort of start a separate clock
ticking when the function is
called and when the recording
function itself is finished
recording and so we keep track
of how much time we spend
recording and we log that
at the end of the request.
We also log how much time
actually to write the complete
set of data to memcache.
So I highlighted every
request that actually
has Appstats activated.
Logs one line in the
application logs.
You can see this very easily in
the administration console, but
just by going to logs and
clicking on show all records
with level info or better.
And so you'll see these
messages that say, saved.
That just means something was
saved by Appstats to memcache.
Actually for debugging
purpose it mostly shows
the memcache key.
Then it shows the size of
the small record it wrote.
The summary is typically
maybe 100 bytes, 150.
Then it shows the size
of the full record, 100
K is pretty typical.
Then it shows the overhead.
So in this case we only spent
four milliseconds recording the
data, but then we spent
another, almost 50 milliseconds
writing that data to memcache
because here analyzing
100K takes a little time.
It also actually logs a link
back into the Appstats UI
if you've done it right.
Now let's do a
little calculation.
How much data is going
to put in memcache?
Now it's important to
understand that Appstats
doesn't sort of record
an infinite amount of
data in the memcache.
That would be bad because we'd
sort of be pushing all your
applications data that is
useful for actually making your
application faster, we'd be
pushing that out of memcache
if we filled it up.
So we actually only record the
most recent 1,000 requests.
The way we do that is actually
by cleverly hashing the time
stamp of the request to a
memcache key, so all the
requests at some point those
keys start rolling over
and you'll just be
overwriting old logs.
And of course, the actual time
stamp is also contained in
the records so the UI knows
what the actual time was.
It doesn't only have
the hash of the time.
So if we store 1,000 keys and
a typical key stores about
100 kilobytes of data that
would be 100 megabytes.
In the grand scheme of memcache
I wouldn't call that a drop
in the bucket, but it's
certainly not very much.
The typical amount of memcache
data that you're allowed to
have is much larger than that.
So we'll still have the
questions, so well, is it fast
enough if my application is
super, extremely popular?
Now Rietveld is not super,
extremely popular.
It has maybe one or a few
QPS in the best of cases.
For Rietveld we've turned it
on, I think about half a year
ago and we've never gone back.
We've just kept it on all the
time and it works great.
Actually, I looked recently
at the logs and the
typical request about 20
milliseconds at the most is
attributable to overhead.
So since the typical request
in Rietveld takes about
half a second to run.
That is not the
important at all.
Now if you have a very popular
application, if you're like 100
or 1,000 QPS you might not
want to store data about
every single request.
First of all, you've probably
already done some optimization
to get to that level of QPS,
but moreover if you're only
saving the 1,000 most recent
requests you'll end up having a
fairly random sampling
of requests anyway.
So what you can do there is
actually use a specific
configuration parameter for
Appstats that lets you say,
only record randomly say 1% or
5% of all requests or 0.1%.
And by using that you'll sort
of completely reduce the amount
of overhead that Appstats
applies to your application
because it's like the overhead
for one request times like
1%, which is almost nothing.
Now if you want to know
how much this costs, 20
milliseconds every second for
example, I think would be
under $1 of CPU time or so.
If you turn this on-- and I'm
not sure I'm even doing this
calculation right, but I did
look at how much you would
actually pay in dollar costs
for this and it's only a very
small amount of money each day
even if you turn it on full
speed, so I wouldn't
worry too much.
At the same time, you might
try it out first in SDK.
When I first wrote the tool I
actually learned more from
pointing it at my application
when running in the SDK because
even a single request, it was
so obvious which things I was
doing wrong that I didn't even
have to run it in production
for a long time.
If you want to configure
Appstats in Python it's four
lines of Python code that you
can literally just cut and
paste from the documentation.
There's no additional tailoring
for your application required.
You put these four lines into a
file named appengine_config.py
in the top level directory
of your application.
And deploy your application
and now that application
is recording.
You can check the logs
in admin console.
Make sure to look for
info level logs and you
can check that it's
actually saving stuff.
To be able to view the user
interface you have to
add these two lines.
Again, literally these two
lines do your app load YML
file and them point your
browser to slash stats.
If somehow slash stats is
already a URL in your
application you can actually
map it to something else as
long as in the end
it ends in stats.
The UI script is smart enough
to only let administrators
access this data, so you don't
have to worry that your users
are going to look at the
statistics of your app
and figure out a DOS
attack or something.
In Java the mechanism
is different.
It's adding 10 or
20 lines of XML.
The basic ideas is the same.
Very simple cut and paste,
redeploy and you're
in business.
And for details see the
Java documentation.
Just type Java App Enginge,
Appstats in your browser
and you'll find it.
For Python users
there's one caveat.
When we first released two
years ago all our documentation
had as an example, sort of in
their hello world example code
something called wsgiref
handler CGI handler as the way
to sort of start your
application assuming your
application is using the WSGI
framework, which all Python
apps pretty much do.
All Python web frameworks.
That doesn't actually
work right.
There's some other reasons why
WSGI ref dressed handlers is
not a good thing to use so
there's a web app specific
funtion, run_wsgi_app that you
have to use amd even though you
import this from web app, which
is App Engines own sort of
miniature web framework, it
doesn't mean that you have to
use that web framework for the
rest of your application.
You can still use Django
or whatever you like.
So there's more you can do in
the configuration and I'm
actually not going to say that
much about this except that you
download the SDK, search for
the Appstats and then in that
Appstats directory find
a file named
sample_appengine_config.py and
it has commented out blocks of
configuration variables with
explanations of exactly why
they're there.
And using this you can sort
of change things like
the key rotation scheme.
If you want to spend more time,
more memcache space to say for
example 10,000 keys you can
change to key rotation scheme
If you want to reduce the space
used up for stack frames.
You can sort of change the
maximum stack depth that is
recorded reported or how many
variables per frame or how
many bytes to store for
each variable maximally.
You can tell it to skip certain
frames or you can tell it to
select only certain events and
the randomized fraction of
all events is actually
a special case of that.
You can select on things like,
what user was logged in or what
IP address did it come from or
the presence of a certain query
parameter or anything else
you can gather out of the
request headers actually.
And then there's the path
normalization, which is
probably best shown
by looking at this.
So these x's I put in by
a little function that
does path normalization.
Because in Rietveld every
issue has its own URL.
Because we wanted sort of the
same code is responsible
for those of course.
So we want to map all these to
the same key and so slash 1, 2,
3, 4, 5 slash div slash 1 slash
2 is mapped to slash x slash
div slash x slash x and let's
look at the other guy.
Lost it.
Doesn't matter.
OK, so that's the stuff you can
do with advanced configuration
and I see we have almost half
an hour left so say 10-15
minutes for questions.
That gives me 10-15
minutes for some specific
performance issues.
And first I sort of want to get
on my soapbox and say you, if
you ever wrote an App Engine
app there is most likely a
performance issue in your app
that you're not familiar with.
And the reason is that when
you're testing your app you're
thinking much more about
correctness than about
performance in most cases.
Now of course, after
correctness comes performance,
but I hope we've all learned
that thinking about performance
before you've even reached
correctness is ludicrous.
So things like unit testing
frameworks make it very
easy to check for correct
working of her application.
Not so easy to check for sort
of maintained performance
characteristics.
Typical testing procedures,
whether it's manual testing or
automated testing doesn't
really look for performance
issues specifically.
Also, often the performance
issues are sort of a little
bit here, a little bit there.
Two gets you could
combine into one here.
A get over there that you
don't need at all or only
in certain cases there.
And it's hard to sort of tell
the difference between my app
is slow because well yes, I'm
using it on the internet.
Of course the internet,
sometimes it's slow.
It could be the wireless
in the building.
It could be some piece of
server infrastructure that you
have no control over or maybe
your application is actually
doing something very
inefficient with remote
00:33:32,058 --> 00:33:32,038
procedure calls.
All those things sort of
blur together so you don't
necessarily look at that.
So here is, in a before and
after pictures quickly,
why it matters.
And this is actually from
a blog by Jens Scheffler.
This is a very simple demo app
and the first version takes
about almost 400 milliseconds
real time to execute.
And what it does is it fetches
20 objects from the datastore.
One at the time.
So it's a four loop and
in the four loop is a
datastore get call.
And the second version, which
performs exactly the same
amount of work, it also gets
those very same 20 objects, but
it uses a single batch RPC to
pass 20 keys to the datastore
at once and now it only takes
200 milliseconds to execute.
It's sort of an indirect proof
that this is actually doing the
same thing as the red bars.
The red bars represent how much
you're being charged for all
those datastore operations
and to some extent for the
CPU in your application.
So the red bar here is about
500 milliseconds long meaning
that you're charged 500 virtual
milliseconds for those
operations and here it's
actually 440 I think within the
natural variability of
the cost of requests.
Because the datastore is
actually fetching the same 20
objects for you it's natural
that you're being charged
the same amount.
However it's doing it twice as
fast at only 200 milliseconds
rather than 400 hundred.
So your users see a huge
improvement and so this
is always important.
So issue number one and this is
sort of the most basic one.
This is where you start off
when you're first looking at
performance for an app that
you haven't looked at
performance at all.
The problem is you don't
actually know what to cache.
So what do you do?
Well you could start thinking
about it, sort of analyze, what
requests are the users making?
And try to follow the code path
through your application.
And very quickly you get lost
because you don't actually know
if it's taking this or that
branch of a particular if.
What you do instead is you link
your application with Appstats,
configure it, run it and now
you'll see immediately which
parts of your application are
used, are making the most
RPC calls and now you know
where to start optimizing.
And often you didn't even know
that every single request was
touching a certain part
of the datastore.
That's one of the things that
always surprises me, how many
sort of hidden requests are in
some generic piece of code that
you sort of forget about
because you wrote it on the
first day of development.
Now you start adding some
caching code and the second
bug-- and this is actually a
state that I have to admit that
shockingly when I started
looking at RPC performance,
Rietveld had actually been in
this state for about
three months.
We had sort of done some
analysis of where is it slow
without Appstats and we had put
some caching in and we had
actually made the right guess
about where to put the caching
in and the caching was
completely working except after
we successfully retrieved an
object from the cache we were
also still retrieving the same
object from the datastore
through some little bug in a
boolean variable that was not
set correctly or a function
that wasn't returning the
right true or false result.
We had not thought of this
possibility in the code.
We had actually checked, we
thought we'd check that the
code was working, caching
correctly by putting
various log messages in.
So the logs showed us
yes it's retrieving the
value from the cache.
It's working.
We didn't actually go to the
point of measuring was it also
faster and Appstats immediately
pointed out that it wasn't.
So a very specific case of
that, this came up a few weeks
ago in a simple internal
app that a colleague wrote.
This is typical caching code.
You try to get something
from memcache.
If it's not in memcache then
you try to get it from the
datastore, so in this
case what we're getting
is actually a query.
We're asking for all
state objects with
a certain property.
And to sort of protect the
innocent I'm not showing what
the name of the property was.
Then we put the result in the
datastore and then we started
iterating over the results.
Well, what you forget except
you can see it if you look at
the bottom of the slide is
that this is not actually
storing the query results.
This store is caching
a query object.
A query object is just a little
piece of memory that stores
what things to query for.
It doesn't actually interact
with the datastore directory.
So this call probably took
about 100 microseconds to
create that query object.
Then we cache that query object
and then the query object
either retrieved from the cache
or recently constructed is
used to execute the query.
This is where all
the time goes.
The solution of course is
to know that this sort of
little pitfall exists.
By other analysis we know and
by sort of bug reports about
seemingly unrelated things we
know that this is a very common
bug in our users applications.
So think about whether you're
actually caching query results
and not query objects.
The solution of course is to
actually fetch the query
results and then up cache those
results because that is what
the author of the code
clearly intended.
Caching a query object is
completely useless because
computing a query object never
takes more than a fraction
of a millisecond.
OK so now we're getting into
very different territory.
Everybody loves abstraction.
Everybody loves to write sort
of little sub packages that
take care of a certain problem
and other sub packages that
take care of a different
problem and they don't talk to
each other because that way you
reduce coupling between your
code and then you layer other
things on top of these and now
suddenly your application
is very slow.
And I love abstraction myself
but I also think it's very
important to be able to see
through abstraction and sort
of look through different
layers and find out what is
happening to performance.
And so a typical problem that
can happen is that two
different parts of an
application are independently
deciding that they need a
certain object from the data
store and they fetch it, but
through completely different
means they end up fetching
the same object.
Which means two RPCs where
you only needed one if you
had the proper caching.
I'll leave it up to you to
decide exactly how to solve
the caching problem.
You could change the
abstraction so that those
results are passed back and
forth by the higher level logic
or you could put in some kind
of low-level caching, write
your own little in memory
caching solution.
The one thing I want to point
out is that the solution for
this particular problem is
never to use memcache because
now you're just replacing
redundant datastore calls with
redundant memcache calls and
remember those memcache calls
still take 5 or 10 milliseconds
where you probably could
just find a pointer to the
object in 1 microsecond.
OK, issue number five.
This is the staircase pattern
that I showed at the start of
this section of the talk.
Just looping over datastore
keys and fetching items one at
a time where you could actually
make use of a batch call.
And this is a problem both when
using the datastore, it's also
a problem when using memcache.
Again, with memcache and
actually in fact with memcache
in particular because most of
the time you spend waiting for
memcache is actually just
network IO, fetching a hundred
items from memcache is just as
fast as fetching one item
assuming that the result
fits in a megabyte.
And so use those batching APIs,
know they exist and for the
database the typical batching
API just passes a list of
keys instead of a key.
From memcache there are
separate multicalls with APIs
with the word multi in their
name that take a list of keys
and then return a dictionary
of mapping keys to values.
Jens Scheffler wrote very
entertainingly about this in
his patterns of doom blog.
OK, I think I have two
more specific batching
external URL requests.
There's not really a very
simple fetch multiple URLs
call, but there is an
asynchronous API for URL fetch.
And here again is a little
before and after thing.
The before we were making I
think, about five URL fetch
calls, one at a time and you
see that the total time spent
there is over 1,300
milliseconds because
each of those calls are
200-300 milliseconds.
Here we use the asynchronous
URL fetch API.
Just look that up in the
documentation or look at Jens'
blog for a sample code.
And all those URL fetches just
execute in peril, you shoot
five of them at once and five
different servers execute them
completely oblivious of each
other and return five results
and you have the same set of
results in 1/5 of the
time effectively.
And while you're waiting
for those URL fetch calls
to complete you could
even do other stuff.
So if sort of the structure of
your application is I have to
fetch a bunch of external URLs
and I also have to do a bunch
of datastore and memcache
interaction you can do your
datastore and memcache
interaction while you're
waiting for the external
fetches to complete because
these external fetches are
often like an order of
magnitude slower than
datastore interactions.
So the final one and actually I
want to mention this, but I
really think you should just go
look it up in Nick
Johnson's blog.
Nick just disappeared,
otherwise I'd point him
out and he was wearing
a yellow t-shirt.
So this is another version
of the staircase of gets,
caused in particular by
reference properties.
A reference property is a very
nice thing in the db module
that lets you sort of abstract
away the existence of keys in a
datastore and use a more object
oriented model where for
example, a blog post object has
an attribute that is a blog
author object and this all
works out very nicely and you
can sort of do a query, get 10
blog post results and then pass
those blog post results to a
template and the template will
fetch the blog author object
for each blog post and render
the authors name, which
is retrieved from there.
This is a very nice way of
normalizing your database.
The only problem is that every
object where there is an
attribute fetch of an author
object that is actually
translated into a single
datastore get call because the
reference property code is not
smart enough to realize that
you're actually going to make a
similar call with a different
key or perhaps the same key
from a different post object to
retrieve a different or maybe
the same author object.
You have an efficient query
and then you still have a
staircase of gets after that.
And Nick figured out that the
right solution is to use
reference property prefectching
and this is actually the
simplest version of his code.
In his blog he presents
two more general
versions of this code.
It basically requires using
class properties and a
special method named get
value for datastore.
Look it up.
I think if you Google for
reference property prefetching
and app enginge you'll
certainly find his among the
first two or three hits.
It is a huge improvement
in your applications
in many cases.
So now we have
time for Q and A.
The clock over there says
we have about 12 minutes.
I have documentation links, but
I'm sure a search engine will
find those much more quickly.
I can bring up the wave
and I'm not sure what I'm
supposed to do with it.
So let's see what happens
if we refresh that.
But in the meantime-- it looks
like the refresh it taking
awhile-- if there's someone
in the audience who has a
question please speak up.
AUDIENCE: I think you
mentioned [INAUDIBLE].
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Is there
any way to paralyze what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM:
Funny you should ask.
It isn't yet a standard app
engine feature, but there is a
third party company that has
made available and
unfortunately I've sort of
mislaid the name of the
company, but I'm sure that
searching for asynchronous
datastore requests will
turn something up.
There is an open source library
that lets you do asynchronous
datastore requests and
I believe queries
are part of that.
It's possible that we'll
eventually open up the API and
build that into app engine.
Let me scroll down.
OK, well the first question,
will the presentation Guido
gave be available for download?
I'm particularly interested
in some parts about
optimizing apps.
I'd be happy to
make it available.
It'll probably be a few days.
I know that they're also
recording all the sessions on
YouTube so you should be able
to find it there in
a few days as well.
I promise if there's any way to
sort of upload slides from
presentations to the IO 2010
website I'll do that and
otherwise I'll put it in some
of the app engine specific file
sections on code at Google.com
and post a link to the group.
OK, number two.
Caching is hard to get right,
do you see App Engine adding
support in their
API for caching?
For example, by adding a
prefetch for the query
to make all sum field
data be prefetched?
That's a good idea.
We have been thinking on and
off about providing a higher
level layer of caching, but
because there are different
levels of caching and there are
different sort of requirements
it's really hard to write a
generic, automatic caching
layer that works in all
circumstances and for all
types of applications.
We're still working
on that problem.
But in the meantime it's
probably better to look at some
point solutions like Nick
Johnson's reference property
prefetch, The URL for the
Appstats presentation, that's
really the same as the first
one, what happened there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Yeah,
let's see what happens.
It's coming.
I think there was-- well
that's a great one.
What advice do you have for
users of Appstats on how to
interpret the data gathered
by it and how to optimize
their code using the data?
That's a very generic question
that I actually think the best
answer is watch the video
of this presentation.
I don't think I have like
a one-sentence addition
that suddenly turns you
into an Appstats or
optimization expert.
Appstats puts some overhead on
the profiled application, but I
am wondering how much money
will it cost me if I use
Appstats all the time?
So I tried to mention
that before.
I think it's under a few
dollars a day, even for
a popular application.
But by all means turn it on for
a little while and sort of
check those log messages for
overhand and do the calculation
yourself or maybe if your
application is really popular,
if you're in the 50 QPS club or
something you may be able to
actually see a bump in your
request rates and a bump in
your daily usage reports.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Yes, so
that's a good suggestion.
He suggested that some
APIs could be made free.
Actually memcache is free.
Sending e-mail is free,
URL fetch is free.
The only APIs that we
charge for is pretty
much the datastore.
But since Appstats itself runs
as a user-land library there's
no direct way for discovering
whether the CPU time attributed
to your application is actually
spent in Appstats or in any
other part of your
applications.
So that makes that
a little bit iffy.
If we had a way to separate
that out clearly I
would like to do that.
OK, this one we got.
How bringing a call JVM
online can impact Java
App Engine performance.
Imagine there are similar
concerns for the
pipe and runtime.
Can Appstats provide insight
into the performance f due to
factors related to the
hosting environments?
This is funny that you
should mention this.
I noticed that some Appstats
requests had a very large
charge for CPU time that was
not sort of seemingly matched
by the real time spent
in the application.
Like if the CPU time charged is
two seconds more, two virtual
CPU seconds more than the real
time and most of the real time
is accounted for by RPCs, where
exactly are you spending
that CPU time?
And I just looked in the admin
console logs for that
particular request and realized
that that was a loading request
and sort of, I forget when we
introduced this, but a few
releases ago we started logging
a special message for every
request that is identified
as a loading request.
And sure enough the loading
requests were the ones
that have extra CPU time.
So a simple enhancement that I
want to apply to Appstats is
actually figure out how much
CPU time we've already spent
when Appstats is first invoked
and then we know that that time
is all spent importing the
library and modules
of the application.
So we'll be able to represent
that graphically in a separate
way so you can say a little bit
more about the cost of loading.
We also have some plans for
making the cost of loading an
application less dramatic, but
I don't want this to turn into
sort of an improvised
product announcement.
I don't want to go into
anymore detail there.
Let's see if there are
anymore questions.
Many performance problems I see
are deadline exceeded errors,
anyway to diagnose those?
That's a tricky one.
I mean, if you got a deadline
exceeded there are sort
of two possibilities.
Either your application is just
trying to do way too much work
for a single request and then
the best thing you can do is
using Appstats look at those
requests that don't quite
exceed the deadline, but are
very close because I think when
you actually hit a deadline
exceeded error Appstats will
not have time to necessarily
save all the data.
So that's not very reliable,
but if you're exceeding the
deadline you're also probably,
likely getting close to it in
other requests and so analyzing
the request that make it to the
deadline that like take 29
seconds or even 15 seconds
will probably be very
helpful in that case.
Another unfortunate reality is
that sometimes if we have
certain performance problems in
our datastore cluster it's
possible that applications sort
of on the average will see
more deadline errors than
during happier times.
If those things happen to more
than one or two applications
our developer relations team
usually post to the App Engine
group so you will be notified
of why you were exceeding
deadline errors in
that particular time.
Can I instrument my own code
and have profiling appear in
the Appstats visualizer?
There is actually an API where
you can create a point event
that shows up with a stack
trays, we don't yet have a way
to from the application sort of
indicate a start and end time
for an event, but that would
actually be a fairly simple
thing to add to the API.
If someone wants to help me by
sort of proposing a patch to
do that it'll happen
faster, otherwise it'll
happen eventually.
I think we're through with the
all the moderator questions.
We have a minute left,
anyone in the audience
want to add something?
AUDIENCE:
I have a question about
what if we are just doing
a data pull, right?
Not doing a lot.
[INAUDIBLE]
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Contact
developer relationships because
that's not supposed to happen.
If a single datastore write
fails and it's not because you
did a whole bunch of them, but
it's just like you ran a
little, very limited amount of
time them you make one write
call and it fails, if that is
not due to some kind of
unanticipated back end
error I'd be surprised.
00:58:19,914 --> 00:58:19,238
AUDIENCE:
[INAUDIBLE].
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: No two
cases are actually the same.
Usually our own monitoring
picks up those things because
we monitor things like failure
rate over all applications and
over specific applications, so
spikes in failure rates and
spikes in response times often
immediately trigger pagers and
engineers will go scurry off
and find out what's going on
and fix things if necessary.
So it's not necessary to
do something about it.
You don't need to report
it in general because we
already figured it out.
And unfortunately we're out of
time now, but I'll be available
throughout the conference.
Thanks everyone.